And in a classification problem suppose let us say that there is two class classification
problem and suppose there are two classes red right you know for this, this is the value
of x 1, this is the value of x 2 and this is an object and suppose there is the blue
class. Now, if we have a linear function the linear
function cannot give us whether it is red or blue. So, the way we use a linear function
is we are going to find an equation a line you want to going to find a line and we are
going to say that this line distinguishes the red objects from the blue objects. So,
we want this line to separate the two classes. So, of course, this will only work if these
points are linearly separable otherwise also we may be able to separate the points, but
we have to find the error of the classification and we need to minimize the error ok.
So, what we will look at is a way of using a linear function for classification we call
this logistic regression, but logistic regression is basically not a regression problem, but
classification problem. And what it means is basically linear models for classification
the name is a misnomer. So, we are going to have linear models for classification.
Now, if we take a linear function y equal to theta 0 plus theta 1 x 1 suppose this is
the linear function this is going to give us a numerical value right. So, but the classification
is discrete value. So, what we are going to do is one way of looking at it is to take
a threshold we can say if suppose we have a threshold t. So, if we say if y is greater
than t, then we say class 1 or less than equal to t class 2. This is one way of using linear
functions for classification. Another way of using a linear function for classification
is to interpret this numerical value as a probability value. For this what we will want
to do is that if we have this linear function, we want to first make sure that with the output
of this linear function or the output of the model is a value between 0 and 1.
Because we are going to interpret the output of our model as a probability value and you
know that a probability is value between is between 0 and 1, but if you take a general
linear function it can have any value including negative value large values etcetera. So,
we want to impose a transformation we will talk about this particular transformation
later. So, we want to impose a transformation by applying the sigmoid function on this linear
function and the output of this transform function is between 0 and 1. So, sigmoid function
is one specific function whose output is between 0 and 1 and then after we apply this sigmoid
function we can say if this value is greater than 0.5 we treat it as class 1 and otherwise
is class 2 ok. So, if you have a linear function we can either use a threshold or we can convert
it into a probability value treat it as a probability and a probability more than half
and less than half based on this we can distinguish these two classes.
So, these are somewhat equivalent, but we will use this formulation ok let me rub this
up. Now, let us see what type of transformation we can do suppose we have you know there is
a function of Z right and this function we want to any value Z we want to map it between
0 and 1. So, this red function that you are showing is a function which takes any value
of Z and squashes it between 0 and 1 ok. If you look at G at negative infinity it approaches
0 at positive infinity it approaches 1 at 0 GZ is 0.5 ok. So, what I am showing is a
depiction of the sigmoid function which is given by this equation sigma Z equal to 1
by 1 plus e to the power minus Z it is such a function that if you apply this function
on any Z, any Z negative positive any value the output will be between 0 and 1 ok this
is the sigmoid function ok Z is any value in real and the output is between 0 and 1.
Now we will use this sigmoid function to our benefit ok. So, what we are going to do this
is my linear function what we have been talking about so far. So, we will take input as X
compute the linear function theta dot X or theta transpose X as we discussed and apply
the sigmoid on that and what we will get the output is a value between 0 and 1 and we will
interpret this as a probability of belonging to a particular class.
So, now because we have two classes this is binary classification problem we have two
classes we say 0 class and 1 class we have two classes we name them 0 and 1 and we say
output of this that is sigmoid of theta dot X is the probability of belonging to class
1 and 1 minus H theta X is the probability of belonging to the class 0 ok. So, if we
want a classification not just a probabilistic value we can say if H theta X is greater than
equal to 0.5 then we say class 1 which is equivalent to saying Z equal to theta 2 X
greater than 0 because for the sigmoid function you know you can see you can just work it
out it is very easy simple function you can find at the point 0 the sigmoid function gives
sigmoid of 0 gives you 0.5 and if Z is positive sigmoid of Z is greater than 0.5 if Z is negative
sigmoid of Z is less than 0.5. So, Z equal to theta dot X greater than equal to 0 means
that H theta X is greater than 0.5 Z equal to theta dot X less than 0 means H theta X
is less than 0.5 ok. So, you can use thisyou know. So, you could actually use this threshold
function which greater than 0 means positive less than 0 means negative, but this threshold
function is not differentiable sigmoid function is a smooth version of the threshold function
and we will use it because we want to use gradient descent.
Any questions on this? Can you show the questions? Is there any way to select the optimal starting
value of theta you know when we do linear regression it does not matter what value of
theta you choose you will always get to the global minima. If you are doing more complex
functions then there are some tips and tricks which will be talked to in other classes ok.
Alpha part ok. So, alpha is you know. So, you have this function you find that there
is a gradient you take a small step alpha is the step size. If alpha is small you will
move from here to here, if alpha is large you will move from here to here, if alpha
is very large you will move from here to here. Does that answer your question? Ok thank you
let us resume. So, these questions you please take tell me whenever they are there ok.
So, what we said is that we want to use a linear function. So, we use a transformation
using the sigmoid function. So, that the output of the linear function takes me to a value
between 0 and 1 ok. Now so, what it means is that when sigma of z sigma of the linear
function is equal to 0 sorry equal to 0.5 that corresponds to the decision surface.
So, on one side we have class 1, the other side we have class 0. So, this is my class
1 and these are my class 0 ok. Now, in order to learn this decision surface we want to
devise an optimization algorithm ok. Now, so for that we will come up with a specific
loss function, other loss functions are possible, but we will talk about this specific loss
function. So, for that let us fall back to the probabilistic interpretation. So, we want
that the decision surface is sigmoid of theta dot x is equal to 0.5 and we interpret probability.
So, we are saying that this sigmoid of theta dot x this is my model, my f theta x is equal
to sigmoid of theta dot x ok this is my model and we are interpreting f theta x as the probability
of belonging to class 1 ok. So, f sorry f theta x is probability of class 1 that is
probability y equal to 1 given x ok and 1 minus f theta x is probability of y equal
to 0 given x. So, this is the way we are interpreting the output of our model f theta. Now, given
this interpretation let us you know come up with a loss function. So, what do you want
if it is class 1 you want probability of y by x to be very close to 1, if it is class
0 you want this probability to be very close to 0 ok.
Now, we want to measure whether it is how much it is close to 1, if the actual y is
1 we want sigmoid of theta dot to be close to 1 this is the what we want, but we want
to be close you know close to 1 ok. So, how close to 1? So, if it is close to 1 our loss
is 0, if it is you know not so close to 1 we will have a loss and what is the loss we
define it as the negative log probability. So, y hat equal to sigmoid of theta dot x
and we say minus log y hat is my loss function. So, if y hat is 1 what is log of y hat it
is 0 just let me finish I will take the question. If y hat is 1 the loss is 0 ok. So, if you
plot minus log y hat this is the plot we are showing here, if you plot this when y hat
is 1 the loss is 0 and for other values of y hat y hat is between 0 and 1 this shows
the loss function ok. So, negative log y hat is taken as a measure of the loss.
Now, if the actual class is 0 the probability is given by 1 minus y hat and that should
be close to 0 again we take. So, 1 minus y hat that should be close to 1 y hat should
be close to 0 1 minus y hat should be close to 1. So, negative log of 1 minus y hat gives
me the loss ok. Now, if you take one particular example it can be y is 1 or y equal to 0 for
one example. Now, if y is 1 the loss is minus log y hat if y is 1 1 minus y is 0. So, the
second term can be ignored ok. And if y is 0 then the first term is 0 the second term
is 1. So, if y is 0 the first term is ignored the second term gives me minus log of 1 minus
y hat. So, I have a single equation which considers both the cases for y equal to 1 or y equal
to 0. If y equal to 1 only the first term is there second term becomes 0 if y equal
to 0 only the second term is there. So, this is an expression of my loss function for a
single example. Now, what is y hat? It is h theta x and what is h theta x? h theta x
is sigmoid of theta dot x ok. So, we write the loss function as minus y log h theta x
minus 1 minus y log 1 minus h theta x this is my loss function.
Now, I will take the question. Now, let us just we can put the question. How does gradient
descent minimize loss? I will come back to it after I finish you know otherwise I will
miss the flow. I think we will take this question if there are any particular question for this
thing that we are teaching now we can have the questions now. These questions refer to
what I taught earlier I will take this questions after I finish this part ok.
Any question for this part? Multiple class will coming to this we are only talking about
binary I told you very clearly. Now, we are talking about binary classification ok let
us resume. Questions on the first part we will take later ok. Now, let us come back
to what we were doing? Is there a way to clean everything? So, we use the negative
you know negative log loss. This is also called the cross entropy loss. This is a very popular
loss function for classification and what is this loss? It says you look at you know
suppose a particular class suppose the actual class is y equal to 1 or in a multiclass class
classification problem suppose the actual class is y equal to red. So, you look at what is
your model outputting as the probability? Ideally the model should output probability
equal to 1 whatever the model outputs you take the negative log probability of that
class ok. So, that is the loss for a single example and you sum it up and take the average
for m examples. This is your negative log loss. This is the negative log loss or cross
entropy loss for one example this is the average loss for m examples. So, this is the loss
function that we are going to consider and then now let us use our friend the gradient
descent algorithm. We said that for linear regression gradient descent algorithm is not
required because we have an analytical solution, but for logistic regression you know we do
not easily get an analytical solution for this where we have the minimum value of this
function, but we can still use gradient descent and the good news is that this function is
also a convex function. This is a convex function this has a single minima, so we can use gradient
descent. There is no analytical solution, but we can use gradient descent. So, the same
algorithm that we used earlier we can use here only because the equation is different its
gradient will be different ok. So, we have to now differentiate this function
with respect to theta 0 and theta 1 and we if we differentiate it right if we differentiate
it we find the solution that solution is this ok and we can use this in a same function
as we did earlier. Does the solution look similar to linear regression? Well it looks
similar, but it is not the same because h theta is different. What is h theta? It is
now sigmoid of theta dot x ok. So, this is my loss function for classification, this
is the partial derivative and we can use the gradient descent algorithm.
So, we repeat for each parameter that we have we do theta j equal to theta j minus alpha
times this ok and if there n plus 1 parameters we will simultaneously update these parameters
in one iteration and then we can do multiple iterations ok. Now, I did not show you how
to go from this expression to this expression. I can give it as an exercise you can work
it out or you know I can incorporate it in the slide. It is not a difficult thing, but
I did not want to do it you know that log z if you differentiate you get 1 by z and
if you do this you can easily come up with this.
Now, let us compare the solutions for linear regression and logistic regression. The forms
are the same, but here h theta x i is just theta dot x here h theta x i is sigmoid of
theta dot x ok. This is the solution that we get, but by using the gradient descent
and sigmoid is this function that we have shown. So, this h theta x and here h theta
x. Now, I come to your question the what we have shown is for two class classification,
but what we have three classes, four classes, ten classes right. This is an example of multi
class classification. Now, we want to still use linear models, but now if we have three
classes, five classes, ten classes one model will not be sufficient. So, what we are going
to do is that we are going to look at suppose there are three classes, we are going to look
at three linear functions or three sigmoid applied to linear functions, three logistic
functions you know sigmoid function is also called the logistic function that is why we
are called it logistic regression. So, we have one function to separate glue from
non-glue, another function to separate yellow from non-yellow, a third function to separate
red from non-red. So, we will now have three linear models. One for each class if you have
k classes for each class we have a linear and a linear model to separate that class from
the rest right. So, now we will have many parameters, we will have theta 1 vector and
the parameters for the first linear function, theta 2 vector for the second class and if
there are k classes we will have dot dot dot theta k for the kth classes. So, we will have
k linear functions, each one will have a number of parameters.
Now what we are going to do? We are going to say that sigmoid of theta 1 dot x is the
probability of class 1 given x, sigmoid of theta k dot x is probability of class k given
x. And we use the same loss function that we discussed earlier, we will have if a particular
object belongs to class i we will look at sigma of theta i dot x and we will take the negative
log of this as the loss of that ok. But before that wait before we come to that,
now for a particular input object x suppose there are three classes. So, we have found
theta 2 theta 3. So, we have found sigma of theta 2 dot x equal to probability plus 2
given x. Suppose this is class 3 given x. So, this is my P 1, this is P 2, this is P
2. Now, so we could interpret these probabilities they do not sum up to 1. So, what we really
want is that we want to compute this expression so that they sum to 1 and for this what we
are going to do instead of separately finding out the probabilities. Now what we are going
to do is let me erase this. We are first instead of finding the probabilities first we could
find the probabilities first, but what is usually done is that you have this three linear functions
let us say theta 1 dot x 1 you know you do not apply any sigmoid do not apply the sigmoid.
We say that S 1 equal to theta 1 dot x 1 sorry x S 2 equal to theta 2 dot x S 3 equal to
theta 3 dot x. Now, we have not used any sigmoid function please note sorry I have S 1 S 2
S 3. Now, I want to transform from S 1 S 2 S 3 to P 1 P 2 P 3 such that each of P 1 P
2 P 3 is between 0 and 1 and their sum equal to 1. So, sigma P i we want to be 1 this is
what we want. So, for that the transformation that is used is for probability y equal to
k given theta we say that you do exponential exponential of theta k x divided by summation
of exponential of theta j x. In this case let us simplify this. So, we will say e to
the power S 1 divided by e to the power S 1 plus e to the power S 2 plus e to the power
S 3 this is the this is equal to P 1. So, for P 2 we will have e to the power S 2 divided
by e to the power S 1 plus e to the power S 2 sorry and for P 3 we will have e to the
power S 3 divided by e to the power S 1 plus e to the power S 2 plus e to the power S.
So, given this linear functions three linear functions or in general k linear functions
we have a transformation which takes the outputs of this linear functions let us say S 1 is
through S 3 and converts them to values P 1 P 2 P 3 with sum 2 equal to 1 and each of
them is between 0 and 1. Now, that is my j theta that gives me my loss and we use the
negative log loss in order to find the loss. So, if you want to find the summation of the
loss we sum for the m examples and if you want to find average we will divide by m.
But for each example for each of the k classes I will only consider suppose this particular
example belongs to class 2. So, for class 2 I will consider the negative log of P 2. So,
only the term corresponding to class 2 we will take. So, we will take the term for class
2 for all other term we will ignore this those terms right. Suppose example 1 belongs to
class 2 we will use P 2 example 2 belongs to class 1 we will use P 1 and take negative
log of P 1 and we will add them up for these m examples to get the total loss ok. This
is for multiclass classification. So, basically the outputs of the linear functions we use
this transformation to convert them to values which can be interpreted as probabilities and
this transformation is called the soft max transformation which has this form exponential
of you know sk divided by summation of exponential of Si ok.
So, with this I stop I will take questions first I will take questions on this topic
then we will take questions on the previous topic that we taught before the break. So,
first we will take questions on logistic regression. Why are we taking negative of log for the
loss function? So, as I explained right I want the probability to be 1. So, negative
log is one possible loss function where if y is 1 the loss is 0 for other values the
loss is more and this is the shape of the curve of the negative log. This is the shape
of the curve of the negative log. Does that answer your question? You could use other
loss function this is one of the popular loss function ok. The negative log function has
this particular form. How to determine which algorithm to apply? Which algorithm you know
it depends on the dataset for if the dataset is such that a simple linear model is sufficient
you can use a linear model if it is not you use other models there is no formula.
Why exponential function is chosen? You know basically an exponential function is just
one possible function you could use other functions this is the popular function. This
exponential function amplifies you know if you look at S 1, S 2, S 3 one of them is larger
it amplifies the value of the larger number ok. Instead of exponential you could have
taken S 1 square divided by sigmoid of S i square it is possible. This is the more popular
function this amplifies the larger value and this is one of the popular loss functions
that people use. Again you know there is nothing to say that this is the function you cannot
take other functions this is the popular functions that people use this has a nice solution and
you know in terms of the derivative and all that. Anything else we can now go back to
the previous questions.
How does gradient descent minimize loss? So, suppose this is your curve and you have chosen
a particular value of your parameter theta at step 0. Now you want to reduce the loss
to reduce the loss you see that if the gradient is in this direction the best value is in
the opposite direction. If gradient is in the in this direction upwards the best value
is in the opposite direction ok. If you take any particular value on a curve forget about
machine learning gradient descent machine learning etcetera. If you have any function
you want to find the minima of the function ok local minima of the function at this point
you find the derivative. If the derivative is positive that means the local minima is
in the negative direction. If the derivative is negative it means the local minima is in
the positive direction. So, if the derivative whatever is the derivative if you want to
go to a local minima you have to move in the opposite direction and that is what gradient
descent is doing ok. I hope you understand now. All these estimators satisfy unbiasedness
or that is not a requirement. What are the bare minimum criteria these estimators need
to follow? You see that these estimators that we are looking at you know first of all where
is the estimator? Estimator is when we are taking the average when we are taking the
average loss that is where the estimator lies. In the gradient descent algorithm we are estimating
the gradient based on m examples that is where the estimator is and we are using an unbiased
estimator mean is an unbiased estimator. After that we are using this optimization
algorithm the gradient descent which I just explained ok. The estimator the average is
the only estimator that we are using which is the mean and whose properties you have
already discussed it is unbiased inconsistent etc. Next question I understand that in both
cases we are updating theta by subtracting alpha multiplied by the slope. When the slope
is positive we subtract no no we are doing minus alpha slope. If slope is positive we
are going in the negative direction if the slope is negative we are going in the positive
direction. Alpha is always positive alpha is between 0 and 1 alpha is positive if slope
is negative we are taking a positive step if slope is positive we are taking a negative
step alpha is always positive any other question? At theta 0 theta 1 are all loss parameters
of each x theta 0 theta 1 are parameters. So, y equal to theta 0 plus theta 1 x right
theta 0 and theta 1 are parameters of the function or inlogistic regression we have
y equal to sigmoid of theta 0 plus theta 1 x that theta 0 and theta 1 are the parameters.
The loss function is with respect to the output and the desired output ok. So, we are trying
to by trying to minimize loss we are trying to find the optimum values of theta 0 and
theta 1 ok. Theta 0 theta 1 are the parameters suppose theta 0 and theta 1 are you know some
values 0.1 0.2 there will be some loss you will get loss l 1. If theta 0 theta 1 are
some other values let us say 0.3 0.1 you will get a different loss. Our objective is to
find that theta 0 theta 1 for which the loss is the smallest. So, loss is a function of
the parameters right when we have mean square loss the loss is function of the parameters
or we have negative log loss loss is a function of the parameters we want to find those values
of the parameters which minimize the loss. Can you go back to the question again I am
not sure I answer the question. This I have already answered theta 0 theta 1 are parameters
we modify the parameters. So, as to minimize loss any question after this good books offline
I will tell you some standard books on machine learning ok. Thank you ok sorry I kept you
waiting. Thank you ma'am.